hey this is presh talwalkar and you're
watching mind your decisions
here's a really fun geometry problem
start with rectangle abcd that measures
four centimeters by 16 centimeters
we're going to fold this rectangle over
line m n
such that point c goes to point a
the question is
what is the area of the resulting
pentagon
m n d prime
i thank himanshu from india for
suggesting this problem
it appeared in a math competition and
you had about one minute to solve this
problem
now you were given four multiple choice
answers but to make things a little more
interesting i'm not going to present
those answers to you so you might take a
little bit longer than a minute to solve
it i certainly did
but it's a fun problem
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for a
solution
so i'm going to present two different
ways to solve this problem i'll first go
over a little bit of a longer way
so we'll start out by folding this
rectangle over line m n
let's forget the centimeters and just
focus on the values
let's label a n as x
now since the entire side a d is 16 that
means nd will be 16 minus x
similarly let's label b m as y that
means m c will be 16 minus y
now when we fold over this rectangle the
distances will be preserved so let's see
what happens
so c prime m will be 16 minus y
d prime n will be 16 minus x
and the distance from a to d prime
will be 4 because that'll still be the
same distance as a b
we can solve for the area of the
pentagon by solving for the area of
three different triangles
we have the triangle of a d prime n
the triangle a b m and the triangle a m
n
so let's solve for each area of each
triangle
now triangle a d prime n is a right
triangle so by the pythagorean theorem
we have 4 squared plus the quantity 16
minus x squared is equal to x squared
this can readily be solved that x is
equal to 8.5
so let's input that value
now let's solve for the area of triangle
a d prime n
this will be 4 times 7.5 divided by 2
and we get an area of 15.
similarly triangle abm is a right
triangle
by the pythagorean theorem we have 4
squared plus y squared is equal to the
quantity 16 minus y squared
and then we get y is equal to 7.5
so it turns out the triangle abm is
actually congruent to triangle a d prime
n
we can use these dimensions to get its
area is also equal to 15.
finally we need the area of triangle amn
well we know one length is equal to 8.5
and here we have its height which is
equal to 4.
so we can solve for the area of triangle
amn as 8.5 times 4 divided by 2 and we
get the result of 17.
now we can solve for the area of the
shape by adding up 15 15 and 17 and we
get an answer of 47 square centimeters
so that's one way that you can solve the
problem
but there's a slightly shorter way if
you think about it
now let's go back to our rectangle
its area will be 4 times 16 which is 64
square centimeters
now let's label a n as x and nd as 16
minus x
so what happens to the area of this
shape when we fold it over
well this new shape is actually going to
have the same area as the original shape
except we lose some area to the
overlapping triangle of amn
so we take the area of the original
shape and subtract out this lost area to
overlapping area
we will get the resulting area of this
pentagon
and once again the reason is that when
we fold the rectangle the new shape has
the same area as the original shape
minus the lost overlapping area of amn
so all we need to do is calculate the
area of amn
we can do this like before we first
solve for the value of x by the
pythagorean theorem
and then we calculate the area using one
side of 8.5 and the height of 4.
so we get that amn has an area of 17
square centimeters so then the area of
the pentagon will be 64 minus 17 which
is 47 square centimeters
did you figure it out and which method
did you use
thanks for watching these math videos
which can be watched for free on youtube
inspire and build confidence for people
around the world and they have over a
hundred million views please subscribe
for free to get the newest videos and
email me a puzzle or math topic presh
and mindyourdecisions.com
if you so choose you can check out my
merchandise on teespring you can check
out my books which are listed in the
video description and you can support me
on patreon for exclusive rewards thanks
for watching and thanks for your support